les chineurs étaient de sortie dimanche
de juin 600 exposants présents pour
cette 30e édition du marché artisanal
une institution et un choix
extraordinaire il ya des chances qu'ils
sont très conviviaux très sympathique
c'est l'adn même de loisirs si c'est le
grand marcheur 6e s'il fallait garder
assez l'événement sexuelle il a
l'occasion de se débarrasser de vieilles
affaires après son grand ménage de
printemps un peu de tout ce qu'on sait
que notre fils n'utilise plus par
exemple comme il est petit grandi il
faut forer site les faire profiter les
autres
et le visiteur des citrons paris fils
entre les rue robespierre du parc et
l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
une petite bête s'ennuie sur sa banquise
arcisienne niant que ces exposants tu
fasses l'animation quoi les affaires ça
se passe très très bien
les gens sont accueillants et puis
j'aimerais bien trouver un petit
un papa pour une maman pour ce petit
pingouin
ce que je peux poche travaille toute la
journée espérons pour ce petit pingouin
qu'il ait trouvé preneur pour le reste
la commune avait mis en place des points
relais pour se débarrasser tout en
réalisant une action solidaire